je le donne je n'arrive pas à réparer
mon réveil
ils font grève puis cette vie là mais
mon tournevis et roro
kazemi droit elle et on a aurais tu un
tournevis plus petit que celui ci lignac
on les mauvais ouvriers qui ont de
mauvais outils je vais te trouvais ça
alors ça alors je n'ai plus le moindre
tour ne vit que disait tu sur les
mauvais ouvriers un bon écoute ne
m'énerve pas après tout il suffit de la
trouver autre chose tu n'as qu'à prendre
un couteau par exemple celui là on n'est
pas trop pointu mais c'est quand même
attention de ne pas couper maladroit
alors ça marche
ça marche ça marche ça marche quand tu
vois un grâce à mon intelligence un
tuner vraiment pas des brouillards moi
pas des brouillards et bien moi à ta
place au lieu de recoller le piéton
tabouret comme tu en train de le faire
moi je choisirai une autre méthode ah
bon et et laquelle à bout de ficelle bon
pour casimir tu n'es vraiment pas des
brouillards
du système où c'est toi qui n'es pas les
brouillards c'est toujours moi qui
trouve les bonnes idées pourquoi c'est
la meilleure c'est toi qui ne peux pas
te passer de moi un instant bon c'est
pas d'abord je ne veux pas discuter plus
longtemps j'ai une idée pour savoir
lequel de nous deux est réellement le
plus débrouillard dina toujours ton idée
eh bien nous je vais aller demander à
françois je suis d'accord françois saura
tout de suite que c'est moi le plus
débrouillard moi tu veux dire moi non
c'est moi c'est moi enfin c'est six mois
qui tous qu'ils trouvent toutes les
solutions témoins c'est mon plus
débrouillards c'est mon chez moi
françois oui un homme franc comtois oui
kazemi y est on a dit bon écoute et vous
les jeux celle que
je viens de vous écouter je veux bien
vous écoutez mémoire prix ne parlait pas
tous les deux en même temps parce que
moi je viens de comprendre et du tout
bon ben je t'écoute je t'écoute casimir
j'allais je voudrais quand ils nous
disent à l'hôtel de nous deux est le
plus débrouillard
lequel de vous deux est le plus
débrouillard ouais ouais ben ça c'est
une question très facilement via le plus
débrouillard de vous deux sets à moi
annoncé en réfléchissant bien c'est pas
si facile que ça question comment faire
pour en être sûr et bien
ça y est ça y est j'ai une idée j'ai
trouvé mes amis mes amis pourtant je
vous retrouve ce que je vois à raison
d'être avec vous des toits écoute
françois merci alors voilà ce que nous
allons faire je vous propose de faire
une espèce de course au trésor il s'agit
pour vous de rapporter dans dans deux
heures ce que vous pensez être le plus
beau trésor que l'on puisse trouver dans
l'île aux enfants
merci nous serons lequel de vous deux
est le plus débrouillard alors c'est
vraiment trop facile il ne me faudra
sûrement pas deux heures et moi je serai
de retour dans un quart d'heure et
j'offre tom prix aux vainqueurs joffre
et bien voilà c'est ce magnifique
sachets de bonbons fourrés des concours
est si ça ne dérange personne j'aimerais
bien participer à ce concours
c'est ridicule il était capable de faire
un tel concours
je t'interdis dans l'insulté mon cousin
préférées si j'en suis capable comptera
pour du beurre
non je ne dois pas compter pour du
beurre bon d'accord tu feras le concours
pour de bon vous êtes très vous avez 2
attention à vos marques
prêts
et aux objets j'ai pas dis partez
hippolyte et léonard sont déjà partis
pour chercher le plus beau trésor de
l'île à
seulement moi j'ai aucune idée il
faudrait que j'en trouve une
de toute façon j'ai tout mon temps et je
sais que je peux compter sur les enfants
alors n'est ce pas les enfants je le
savais
quand j'ai voulu saluer dès la page du
terrier pas voter
jeudi matin dans leur cour mais coincé
jusqu'au
j'étoufferai
malheureusement l'aise enfin
sont pas arrivés à temps
ils m'ont tiré fort par les pieds et
j'ai pu respirer
[Musique]
tout en haut d'un mur de pierres apicole
les arbres je dansais
quand il a dit on descend j'ai senti
tout mon sang se glace et
les enfin
ebay à temps
ils ont tendu une
ouverture j'ai pu sauter du mur
leurs feux dans l'île aux enfants je
chante joliment mes chansons
si j'ai la voix qui déraille
mémoire qui défaille
attention
[Musique]
enfin
jean mois
[Musique]
témoin
mais pas
r oui
y avez aimé
en bas
[Musique]
voilà
et
ouais alors
bien bon je crois que maintenant il
serait peut-être temps d'aller chercher
le plus beau présent de lille qu'en
pensez vous bon ben alors venez avec moi
dépêchons-nous 1 il ne faut plus perdre
de temps maintenant à y allons chercher
le trésor on va trouver quelque chose de
formidable je suis sûr vous allez le
voir
bien hippolyte hippolyte s'il ne fait
pas la course au trésor
ils pêchent toi il te reste qu'un quart
d'heure aller vite
mais il se passe quelque chose julie
soir
regarde hippolyte il ne fait aucun geste
il push
mais il le dit aucun nom il est peut
être malade
mademoiselle futile ou êtes vous oui je
suis là je suis dans les buissons julie
mais je suis en train de cueillir de
ravissantes plantes rares mais je me
suis piquée
ces plantes rares doivent être des
orties féminine qui a t'il julie au
regard d hippolyte aux îles
canaries v10 un petit bonjour atone et
d'une et
hippolyte mais les gens
terriblement inquiète hippolyte réponse
écrite mais je rassemble bon courage
pour sauver quelqu'un mais regardez me
suis tu t'habilles police ne bouge plus
avant ce programme à hippolyte te dit
quelque chose terra hippolyte et
oui on a regardé je vous rapporte le
plus beau trésor du monde avec qui le
font plus je suis obsédé brouillard et
la personne
et voici
le plus beau trésor de l'île à la plus
jolie de toute les jeunes avec les plus
belles gouttes de rosée et vous allez
m'écouter oui ou non maman regarde dans
quel état se trouve hippolyte qu'est ce
que
c'est chers amis bonjour crois que c'est
moi qui ai gagné
hippolyte tu n'as pas bouger dit c'est
justement parce que pour moi le plus
beau trésor du monde c'est d'être
entouré de mes amis
yayi boni bravo tu as gagné la
récompense vient
lipoly tu exagère
mais le plus beau des trésors
c'est de faire des cadeaux à ses amis
devant le reste du pack nationaux gagny
nom maintenant c'est moi oh oui et bien
le plus beau trésor de l'île à jean les
trouver c'est mon cousin hippolyte a
en